[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record we talk about
whatever we want baby
and joe's gonna drink soon oh really
right now
what's he gonna drink okay i'm gonna
break out this box
and drink some whiskey
or scotch to the harry potter difference
between whiskey and scotch
that's a wine question
oh fine bourbon whiskey this single malt
scotch
bourbon is a lot more caramelly and then
oh wait it's the same thing it says
wisdom
i thought it had to do with where it was
made like like whiskey or something it's
like
yeah tennessee kentucky well i'm not
promoting this brand it's not a brand
new i know
i swear to god ryan has told me this
multiple times and i had still
okay well it says single malt scotch
whiskey okay
it's both i just know that when i had
scotch it tasted more smoky than when i
have just bourbon
whiskey okay so i'm never buzzed well i
was buzzed with you guys uh when we went
to vegas
i had a gin and tonic but me and bart
are never buzzed on camera
and we let you guys have a lot of fun
but
this will be a patreon exclusive so stay
tuned for that
we're going to be joe and bart are
finally going to be buzzed yes doing
buzz jk news
guys keep speaking to us like a third
person joe bart
even though they're right here yep bart
didn't even agree yet by the way yeah he
didn't even know he was invited
cleanly spoke for barbara i'm down for
anything all the time i don't give a
[ __ ]
he's just in the mix the reason why i
got that is because well
if people know their alcohol that's like
a 250 uh dollar
alcohol i yeah i don't want to spend so
much
right yeah i'm not fancy i'm not boozy
because you hold money
it's fake money right i'm talking about
the price of the bottle yeah but here's
the reason why
it's so expensive so like i've always
had a bad relationship with alcohol i
think a lot of people has been following
they know it
i just get headaches i can't enjoy it
bart's very similar in that way
he's probably just a little bit better
than i can than i am with it he can
drink some
stuff but still has a negative like
effect with it
we have a buddy who's basically on the
same plane with
um having a limited ability to like
enjoy
alcohol and he's already done the
process for us like he found
all the ones that were good and he
boiled it down to
really processed like fine alcohol that
are more like aged and whatever
um the high quality alcohol we can
actually drink that without getting sick
so i also didn't drink a [ __ ] ton though
like when we were drinking in your
backyard
i drink just a little bit i think to
really know if it's good for me
maybe i need to drink like a full but
then i guess compare that to other
alcohol that you've had about the same
amount
what's the difference i never really
drink such [ __ ] amounts what were you
drinking my brother
that thing oh okay but then it was like
such a little [ __ ] i'm not like this
much so you're not sure
no but you're able to drink that [ __ ]
amount and enjoy
it without feeling sick it's like me
eating hot sauce i like
take a little tiny piece and go i'm like
oh that's not that bad
i don't know because you have tried
alcohol in the past with the [ __ ]
amounts
and immediately you get red so i'm like
is it better oh no well the other
alcohol
i drink the whole thing and then it just
gets red and i don't like it
but i've also just i've never really
just licked it like i've tried like a
mouse gal mule and steve makes it or gin
and tonic and casey recommend i'll drink
the whole thing
but like after an hour i'm like oh i'm
so tired so i go to sleep and i turn red
i didn't try purple baby purple yeah you
do
i didn't try like a coke what is this
would be the equivalent coke and
japanese we drink this straight yeah
okay uh cutest thing in the world joe
gets a gin and
a gin and chunk
it was to the to the [ __ ] rim of the
glass right all the way up
joe has a sip not even kidding you can't
even tell liquid has been yeah
about 15 minutes later joe to me and
gino and bart he's like
i'm feeling pretty buzzed guys look at
his drink it's completely [ __ ] full
yeah that's kind of crazy i think there
was more more
no i was like i can actually enjoy it
now i just have to dose myself correctly
because now
i was like oh okay so maybe before i was
drinking too much too fast and that's
why i got sick every time
so now i just gotta drink like a little
bit of the ice with the water that
touched the alcohol a little bit and i'm
like okay i can feel the buzz now i feel
great
you go to the bartender and you're like
fill it up
that's probably my shot did you finish
that drink that night no
it was completely full we left the table
it was when we left the table
i think it was honestly spilling over
from the ice melting
yeah it was a joke what i actually got
to enjoy a buzz
with you guys yeah which was really cool
and it's crazy how
sensitive i am i couldn't tell he was
just a little happier than normal which
is already pretty happy
you get purple too or not i don't know
if i get red
yeah i just know that um it's not
pleasant man
drinking [ __ ] sucks for me with
marijuana for me
i love smoking red for marijuana no not
i don't turn a color
i just feel really sick and nauseous and
like
i feel like i am paranoid about
everything and then people are like oh
you're doing the wrong strength because
indica that's the team it's probably
dope i just like
either one i just it doesn't work that's
probably dose
like how much you're smoking that was
like half a hit oh half a hit
oh yeah you're probably just sensitive
to the uh
i just wish it was over so you take big
hits you don't even know it maybe you go
ham i did play a woodwind instrument
she cannot handle it that's funny but
you can you can smoke weed though
my tolerance has gone down like crazy
but yeah i mean i mean yeah i'll smoke
it like it's legal there now
so you can you know we went to a
dispensary it looks like a
supreme it looked like the apple store
wow it was pretty
yeah there were geniuses there like
that'll explain indica sativa and all
these different strains to you and then
can you can you bring a bag in and then
they try to help you fix it that's funny
like in 30 minutes man it's backed up
the strain didn't work
i it didn't taste like blueberries at
all another one of my advices
is is food oh yeah because i think uh
that's something that gets me high
it's addictive too yeah and when i was
out there i'm always looking for
really delicious [ __ ] and um yeah cause
vegas is known to have like
the best of the best in the world the
best chefs
of the world fly in [ __ ] make their
own restaurants and [ __ ]
sick can't beat it yeah sam you would
have never guessed but we went to a
steakhouse
in the circus circus i would only guess
because you texted it to me i know i
know but like
that wasn't our first choice though so
we were just looking like circus circus
wasn't your first
choice what made you guys crazy now
we're like oh we're
feeding for some steak let's get some
good steak and then our cab driver
took us to a place uh that was really
good
and then when we got bistros or
something no it's another one but was it
uh well masters we couldn't go there
because he
you guys were dressed like yeah and
trash no it was like it was like every
single
okay so the journey started where we
were at the dispensary and then we're
like all right now it's time
cause we're hungry as [ __ ] and then the
cat just pulls up and we go in and i'm
like oh do you know where we're going
and bart's like nah the cab was there
and i'm like [ __ ] all right so we gotta
look at the dispenser i didn't even
smoke no no no but then
i was just there just look at the stuff
it was cool yeah the cab driver came up
so i was like
might as well just grab it and then
usually cab drivers know their [ __ ]
right so we're like what's a really good
steakhouse he goes
well there's 2000 here oh or like there
was a [ __ ] ton right he's like choose
from that
and i'm like oh [ __ ] and then so yeah we
went to
one maestro's first which we couldn't
get in because he had a tank top on and
had shorts on
there was another one that he
recommended it was like a cuban one or
whatever but it was packed it was booked
all night yeah we're like whoa and we're
just kind of looking and i found on yelp
and i was like the steakhouse why did
this sound so familiar
and it was at the circus circus and then
the driver was like
oh that place is good and i'm like
it is yeah we thought he was kidding i
was like i don't know if i could trust
this guy anymore
yeah yeah but then i remember i watched
a food vlogger
that went and it it looked really good
so i was like oh [ __ ] it is yeah it's a
secret it's one of those words like
kind of like locals and some people know
about it where you get
legit ass steaks so i was like we gotta
[ __ ] go we got it it's legit because
of the meat is like dry aged
yeah you know so that already sets it
separates from like a regular steak
house
to like like the good ones and you walk
in you know circumstances look at trash
yeah and they're like you know you don't
have to wear clothes here right and
you're like oh yeah no i'm gonna wear
this it's fine
yeah you see like [ __ ] clowns and
arcades everywhere and all of a sudden
you have like this mafia joint looking
steakhouse it has like this old-time
vegas feel and it was dope
and that's why i thought well it's
circus circus they're probably gonna let
us in with like
shorts and a tank top but um what we
were doing is we were calling
steakhouses to see if they had a dress
code right
and i'm like you know what i'm not even
going to do that i'm just going to make
a reservation
and then so i just called ahead and i
was like all right we have a party at
three
at six in five minutes yeah we're just
we'll be there and then we show up
and then i was like please don't tell us
to go home yeah and then they're like
usually we don't let guys in with the
tank top but we'll find a table for you
in the back by the kitchen
wait they literally said that like by
the in the kitchen but they sit by the
back
in the corner yeah we have a we'll hide
you from our exquisite guests that we
normally have
a second second from this part have you
learned from we have standards
yeah i mean usually i know this i know
this about steakhouses where it's
usually like casual you're supposed to
even have a jacket usually like when we
ate for was it casey's birthday or your
birthday
oh casey's yeah like there's a strict
business casual you're supposed to have
your shirt tucked in all that so i know
that about steakhouses
but we just got off the plane checked
out a bunch of houses
and we didn't have time to go back to
our hotel room so we're just hungry well
he also didn't pack any of that anyway
so
i also didn't pack slacks over her hands
he left that part out
yeah i like how he made it sound like he
could like he could have he had the
option to do it normally
you know what um i i used to get a
little bit of like nervousness or
anxiety when i'm like traveling right
yeah
and the plane well let me tell y'all
something this video is brought to you
by fields man
and then so they hooked me up with this
cbd oil yeah and like
i've been kind of like chilling out a
lot because when i go on trips now
i'm able to just before like have my
mind right
and just chill out my body and be like
at a zen state because i'll just
drip a few into my tongue and be like
okay you know i'm just coasting into
this whole situation
and you know whatever happens happens
and then it it just
uh when your body is relaxed i feel like
your mind is also relaxed and then you
start thinking
in a way that's more um like a surfer
more chill yeah more chill and so this
whole trip it's like
whatever's baby i didn't have to worry
about anything yeah feels is a premium
cbd delivered directly to your doorstep
it naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
pain and sleeplessness
it's easy to take place a few drops of
fuels under your tongue and feel the
difference within minutes the thing to
remember about cbd is that finding your
right dose is really important
and everyone's dose is different so
leave room to experiment over the course
of a week or so and you may need to take
more or less to get the effects you are
after for me it's just a couple of drops
baby so like
are you neat to cbd though because feels
offers a free cbd hotline to help guide
your personal experience
fuels works naturally to help you feel
better
there's no high hangover or addiction
join the fields community to get it
delivered to your door
every month you'll save money on every
order and you can pause or cancel at any
time
so if you want to fill your best
everyday fields can help too become a
member today by going to feels.com
off the record and you'll get 50 off
your first order
with free shipping that's such a good
deal feels that's f
e a l s dot com slash off director to
become a member and get 50
off your first order with free
shippingfeels.com
the best thing about you guys is i can
be like let's go to [ __ ] circus
circus tonight
play one dollar craps or five dollar
crap i was like they have one dollar
crap
they did they did at some places yeah
and then let's go to the [ __ ]
mcdonald's on the top of the
of the casino and you guys are like [ __ ]
yeah that sounds sick
why wouldn't we well i know but that's
what you're not bougie like oh
like where's the bottle service and the
hot girls i could do both
like i'll literally one night pay 300
bucks for a meal
and then the next night we'll get like a
budget deal free
shrimp cocktail with a roll of a dice or
some [ __ ] like
i still have a lot of fun um bargain i
think i have more fun
you don't need to be spending lots of
money to have fun like it's like oh what
am i feeling tonight yeah it's like a
treasure hunt you know like for example
well the steaks weren't cheap when we
went to go uh
eat it was like at least 70 something
dollars per
it was fast yeah but it was huge i mean
that's actually a good price
for a steakhouse in vegas too yeah i
mean because you're thinking yeah
i think a dry aged steak and now they
would be like two three hundred dollars
you're bringing up dry age again
can you explain what that means so you
got a regular steak right that you just
get from like
uh the supermarket yeah i was gonna say
a couch from the cow like
you you open the cow drawer and you take
a snake out right how neat
so that's just like it was like i don't
know butcher not too long ago
it's boring already you're falling
asleep so yeah body when you dry agent
and what they do is
they put it in like salt and they put in
like this little vacuum like
refrigerator area
and sometimes they dry age it for a week
or two or three or months sometimes
couple months
what it does is it draws out the
unnecessary moisture
to really get that beefy flavor and it
draws the beefy flavor and
so when you cook it when you take a bite
of it it's like you're not eating just
like mushy flesh it's like a big chunk
of beef
yeah cause like i had seen like uh
i didn't know that that's what they did
to meat because i had seen an entire
fish be covered in salt and put in a
thing
and and so we got served that like dry
aged fish i guess is what
what it's called yes like there is a
huge difference that's a secret
for sushi restaurants like when you
think of oh this sushi
is so good this fish is like super fresh
but then you can taste the fish
they're actually using dry aged fish
that is a ikejime
star style like um i guess
killed which is um they
as soon as you fish the fish out uh they
kick
they kill it really quick by hitting the
head in the brain and then they
um put they poke a hole through the
spinal area
and then they bleed it out so then
there's no moisture and blood
in the system but it's it's probably the
most ethical way of killing a fish
because when they do commercial fishing
they grab the fish
and they just throw it in the back and
it chokes to death yeah versus
yeah a lot of places don't do ikejima
style because
um it's too time consuming where one
person has to sit there
do this put the thing in and all that
but that's the best way you get the best
flavor
all that stuff yeah i saw a video where
a guy
kills a uh a lobster with a knife
by just like chopping it in the brain or
whatever i guess it's the most
human way to do it instead of boiling it
or freezing it a lot like people think
that freezing it they're like it just
falls asleep and
then it's dead it's kind of cold
sebastian no yeah what do they freeze it
for
to kill them go to sleep yeah to make
them go to sleep that's just to kill it
it's not like it's but it keeps it fresh
but yeah what if you go
in and you open the freezer and that
guy's still alive because at the bottom
of the ocean it's pretty cold
so what if you open it he's like i'm
still here oh that's what i mean
you know what's funny is remember all
the paintings on the wall at the
steakhouse they were just different
cows like they had black angus they had
white ingredients but didn't they do
that in japan
yeah with the horse that was one well
not that one but like um
no uh when when you guys bought the [ __ ]
the kobe beef it told you like
what the name was like but his name was
charlie this one's from coleman
yeah yeah well this one's different
because these these are like cow selfies
yeah it was so funny it was the cow like
breaking the fourth wall like looking
into the camera
it was like mona lisa's yeah you're like
are these like
cow memories because the one in japan
it's like
cow animated
it was like cow portraits cow doing a
douche face like yeah
there were like two cows there were two
cows so like mama cow
baby cow that count just one big on
roulette
yeah i kind of prefer it because i i
think people should
associate what they're eating they
should it's just funny
okay yeah it's just hilarious i don't
want to associate what i'm eating unless
i'm
hunting it and killing it myself and
preparing it myself i don't want to know
where my food comes from
someday when we're all growing meat in a
lab which i think will happen
very soon people think and they'll be
pictures of test tubes
and we should have that too petri dishes
[Music]
exactly
[Music]
you